[Music]  collectible action figures of me from  different times in my life for example  there's  [Applause]  [Music]  I was a scrappy little ball yeah these  are hard to find out you press the  button he wets the bed everything yeah  next up there's teen Conan I found a  teen Conan's all those were really big  in the day yeah it's the late seventies  acne the whole thing then there was fat  conan this is a doll yep in the 80s  [Applause]  Turnham is a lot of fun turned out it  was bland euler then from 1993  late-night conan that's when I first  came on television look at that  expression no idea what he's headed for  and then finally the rarest one of all  that one confused summer after college  Conan  [Applause]  I was pretty here they are the  collectible tonin's are sorry  I was happy then this guy looks that is  exactly what I looked like in night I  said that is pretty amazing  you